When scientists began observing microbes,
many of the tools that we rely on today, of course,
had not yet been invented.
Now, microscopes existed, but they were generally
simpler tools.
And they also, of course, lacked cameras that
could take a snapshot of the organisms and
objects being so closely watched.
Still, the scientists were exploring the uncharted
territory of the microcosmos, and words alone
would not suffice to describe the strange
beings they uncovered.
So early microscopic research was not just
a scientific endeavor, it was an artistic
one, relying on illustrations of diatoms and
rotifers and other creatures that could then
be disseminated to those who were curious
to see these new wonders.
One of the most impressive collections of
microbial illustrations was drawn by Christian
Gottfried Ehrenberg, a German naturalist in
the 19th century who amassed thousands and
thousands of geological and biological samples,
and who in turn produced thousands of sketches
based on the observations he made under the
microscope.
Today, we will be taking a bit of a turn from
our normal content, shifting our focus from
microbes to a scientist whose extensive documentation
of them influenced the fields of microbiology
and micropaleontology.
We're going to be talking about Ehrenberg's
life while showing you his drawings, which
come from the collection of his works maintained
at the Museum of Natural History in Berlin.
And we will also share our own videos of those
same species so you can see how the details
he sketched out by hand stack up against what
our cameras can record from our microscopes
today.
So let's start with the early days of Christian
Gottfried Ehrenberg's scientific career.
Born in 1795, Ehrenberg earned his doctorate
in 1818 from the University of Berlin.
In his thesis, he described 250 species of
fungi from around the city, but most notable
was his observation that fungi are borne from spores
and not--as many theorized at the time--spontaneously generated.
Two years later, Ehrenberg joined an archaeological
expedition to Egypt that would end up somewhat
disastrous.
At one point, the funders claimed to have
"lost" the money meant for the travelers.
Then, one of Ehrenberg's compatriots almost
died from a snake bite.
And then later actually died of Typhus.
Despite the physical and emotional trials,
Ehrenberg was able to send tens of thousands
of animal, plant, and rock samples to Germany.
Except that when he returned home five years
later, many of those samples had been damaged
and another bunch had been sold.
This was a discouraging outcome.
But when Ehrenberg was offered the chance
to join the esteemed naturalist Alexander
Humboldt on an expedition to Russia and Siberia
in 1829, he seized the opportunity.
Fortunately, this expedition turned out to
be much less calamitous.
Both of these expeditions provided Ehrenberg
with a wealth of samples to draw from in his
study of the natural world.
And more importantly, they would shape his
fascinations with microbes, which he called
"Infusoria."
Ehrenberg was loyal to his microscope, relying
on the same one for decades to study the "Infusoria"
sampled from various waters.
He uncovered some of the ways these little
known creatures were connected with the larger
world they lived in, like the planktonic microorganisms
he realized were the source of phosphorescence
in the Red Sea, and the diatoms whose silica
casings became part of the Earth.
Now many of the samples he observed under
the microscope were embedded into mica and
covered in Canada balsam.
Magnifying his various specimens 300x, Ehrenberg
drew out what he saw with a fine grey pencil,sometimes
adding pigment using watercolor.
But no man can be correct all the time, and
Ehrenberg’s refusal to update his microscope
may have led to one of his most notable mistakes.
He thought that all of the organisms he observed
must be animals, even the unicellular ones.
In some cases, what he claimed were eggs and
sexual organs were later revealed to be nuclei.
Still, mistakes aside, his work further solidified
the study of Infusoria, and his collections
and remarks on microbial fossils paved the
way for micropaleontology.
While Ehrenberg's later expeditions were not
quite as distant as his first two, this was
an age where naturalists were venturing all
over the globe to gather samples.
And Ehrenberg happened to be corresponding
with quite a few of those naturalists.
They would send him bits of living things,
rock, soil, and more from just about everywhere.
It's like a postcard for your naturalist pen
pal.
Charles Darwin even sent him dust that had
blown on to his ship near the Cape Verde islands.
In 1854, Ehrenberg published one of his most
famous works: Mikrogeologie.
I don’t speak German so I could just say
Microgeology.
It’s a 2-volume text that compiled observations
on North American and European sediments and
the microbes they housed.
The book would cost you $72, which was not
cheap in 1854, but it might be worth it for
4,000 of these illustrations.
Ehrenberg died in 1867, after which his collection
was eventually moved to the Museum of Natural
History in Berlin.
Part of the collection's value lies in just
how vast it is, both in the types of samples
it contains and the geographical range they
come from.
In total, there are more than 40,000 microscope
sample preparations, thousands of specimens
and illustrations, and hundreds of letters.
His daughter Clara helped with both the drawings
and compiling an index to link all these samples
together, which has proven essential in making
sense of his immense work.
But the knowledge contained in this collection
would become hard to reach for some time.
For decades, a mix of war, politics, and finances
kept it inaccessible.
It was even at one point believed to be lost.
Fortunately, that was not true, and in the
late 1960s, curators began to restore it.
Progress was slow and briefly threatened when
in 1982, a fire broke out in the museum's
roof, close to where the collection was stored.
The museum curators responded quickly to save
it, and ultimately these historical documents
survived with only a little water damage.
And through all of these dire situations,
the curators persevered in their intention
to make the collection accessible.
In 1998, they released a CD-ROM containing
scanned images of the illustrations, letters,
and indexes.
And now, if you want to explore the images
at your leisure, the museum has made them
available to download on their website.
And why wouldn’t you?
So there’s a link in the description.
The more recent availability of the collection
has inspired more scientific work.
A group of Brazilian scientists studied Ehrenberg's
records on diatom samples taken from their
country, essentially repatriating data and
allowing for a study of biodiversity across
time.
Another group of researchers extracted and
examined bacteria from some of Darwin's dust
samples, confirming just how resilient bacteria
can be.
Technology, of course, has given us new ways
to document and share the microbial world.
One of the coolest parts of our job as we
assemble each episode of Journey to the Microcosmos
is that we get to spend so much time watching
microbes and appreciating their beauty, a
pursuit that Ehrenberg could surely relate
to.
But the fact that we can record what we see
on video is built on advances in microscopes
and cameras.
Moreover, when we want to share what we see
with the world, we don't have to send you
images via mail or compile them over two decades.
We just hit a button on YouTube, and the whole
world can watch if it chooses.
That same technological progress has made
Ehrenberg's collection more accessible.
In an age of big data, his illustrations and
his documents are a physical trove of information
whose promise we're still understanding.
It's a common mistake to think of science
and art as separate endeavors, but they're
linked by creativity and by the human desire
to make sense of the world around us.
Time and invention have only given us more
ways to engage science and art together, and
in the same way that we've found beauty and
meaning in the stars above us, there are also
answers in the infusoria that surrounds.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
Thank you to all of the curators who protected
Ehrenberg’s work, and also, hey, thanks
to Ehrenberg himself.
I know he’s not around to hear it, but his
work is appreciated.
And of course thank you to all of the people
whose names are on the screen right now.
If you like this show, they’re the reason
it can exist.
They are our supporters on Patreon.
If you would like to join them, check out
patreon.com/journeytomicro.
There’s a link in the description.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes James, you can check out Jam and
Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us every
week, just go to youtube.com/microcosmos to
see what we’ve been up to.